the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Theory video today I
want to do something slightly different
than what I typically do in my videos
lately I have noticed one theory in
particular seems to be gaining some
steam so I wanted to take the time today
to address it by giving my own opinion
on the subject over the last few weeks I
have been getting several emails tweets
and comments basically asking me the
same thing which is do I think Jon Snow
will become the new night king this idea
is becoming more and more popular as we
get closer to the final season so I did
a little searching on Google last night
to try to find the source of the theory
the first thing I noticed was there were
a bunch of different articles already
written about the theory and after
looking at those it eventually led me to
a source and I did link the source down
in the description of the video now I do
want to say I highly doubt this was the
first person to come up with this idea
but the articles I saw did use this as
their source so I figured I would do the
same thing because I do like to give
credit when I can now what I want to do
first is rave the theory about Jon Snow
becoming the new night king then I will
give my own opinion that way I can just
respond to all those questions at once
because I know many of you have been
asking the same question so let's jump
into the Jon Snow and I Qing Theory the
person who wrote this version of the
theory said hello this is my first time
typing something like this and English
is not my native language I also want to
add I've not read any of the books and
I'm not as deep into the history and
lore so don't be too harsh on me I'm
sure someone else already came up with
this idea but among the many theories
about the night King and everything
regarding him this is the one that seems
believable so me and a friend were
discussing episode 7 a game of Thrones
and after quite some time of talking
absolute nonsense and fabricating
unrealistic scenarios it turned into
something we could both believe in I'd
love to hear responses and even
arguments I'm sure they're out there
that will completely destroy the theory
my friend called it the
Davy Jones theory as it is similar to
the plot twist and Pirates of the
Caribbean Will Turner has to take the
role of Davy Jones because the Flying
Dutchman always has to have a captain
the idea is in as the prophecy foretells
it that a Zora hi will save the realm
from the night King what we talked about
was the idea that the night King is
actually immortal there is no method to
kill him for good and even the children
of the forest can't control or kill him
the only way you beat him is that this
is just one possible way it might happen
someone has to pull out the dragon glass
that is in his chest that created him in
the first place by doing this the night
King would die but unlike what happens
when someone kills a white Walker none
of the creatures that I King created or
turned would die instead they would lose
the mind-controlling effect the night
King has on them and they would start
doing whatever they want
ie rampaging around Westeros to prevent
this scenario from happening someone has
to take the place of the night king by
stabbing himself with the previously
extracted dragon glass dagger by doing
this the person in our mind Jon Snow
would sacrifice himself for the greater
good gaining control over all the whites
and white walkers he would then lead
them back past the wall into the north
where they would stay like it has been
before since the last long night here we
had two ideas on the details and we
couldn't agree on one so I'm gonna
mention both after becoming the new
night king they kill off all the White
Walkers and whites but they still can't
kill the night king he would then
seclude himself in the north as to not
hurt anyone else
the White Walkers and whites are still
there and he leads them in the north so
he can watch over them so how would this
tie in together with the previous azor
Ahai mentioned in the tales well in our
mind the same scenario we have now in
this series has happened before which is
known as the long night at that time the
children of the forest and the first men
United and they were able to extract the
dragon glass dagger as mentioned above
azor Ahai then sacrificed himself by
stabbing himself with a dagger to gain
control after he became the new night
king he was so conscious about himself
he stole at his personality and memories
so he the children of the forest and the
first men built the wall in Union
the night king using ice and maybe even
using the undead as help and the
children would use their magic to add
protection to the wall and the first men
would build castles along the wall and
they would form the Nights Watch
after that the night King would seclude
himself for in the north where no one
else could survive now over time since
the long night the personality of the
former azor Ahai slowly began to decay
and he finally turned into what we now
see in the series as the night king at
some point the vanishing personality of
azor Ahai could no longer hold the evil
in check
that was lingering inside him at that
point the night king started moving
again returning from the far north and
slowly started creating new white
walkers and whites as he had before thus
creating and never ending ever repeating
cycle of someone becoming the night King
so basically some of this theory they
are saying the night King cannot be
killed he can only be replaced what he
thinks will happen is Jon Snow will
become the new night king then banish
himself to the north in order to keep
the people of Westeros safe but over
time he will start to lose his
personality which will eventually lead
to him becoming the evil version of the
night king all right now before I give
my opinion on the theory I want to make
sure we're all on the same page if you
think Jon Snow will become the new night
king for a different reason make sure
you put it down below because I'm not
sure if everyone is basing their
question off this exact version of the
theory like I said at the beginning of
the video I know many of you have either
been asking me this question or just
telling me you think Jon Snow will
become the next night King but I haven't
seen a ton of good evidence for the
theory yet so if you do believe in the
theory make sure you provide some
evidence to back it up there may be
different versions of the theory that
led you to believe it but the reason why
I chose to read this version was because
when I searched for it on Google the top
articles were based on this one so if
you have different reasons for believing
it just make sure you let me know
in my opinion whoever made this theory
left out one of the best pieces of
evidence from the show when Jon Snow
went into the caves on Dragonstone he
discovered some very old paintings of
the White Walkers and the night King if
you look at the paintings you can see
that it looks completely different from
the night King
we see today so it does appear there may
have been different like Kings over the
years and this actually supports the
theory because maybe the night king does
always have to be replaced this could
also be true for the books as well when
the author george RR martin commented on
the night's king he said this as for the
night's king the form i prefer and the
books he is a legendary figure akin to
land the clever and Brandon the Builder
and no more likely to have survived to
the present day than they have this
could support the idea that there had
been multiple night Kings over time if
you are up-to-date with the books then
you know the night king has not been
revealed yet there are whites and white
walkers but we haven't seen who is
leading them
the only time we hear about the night's
king is when someone is referring to the
legend of the 13th Lord Commander and he
was alive roughly 8,000 years ago but
most people do assume someone is
controlling the whites and the White
Walkers today so even in the books there
may have been more than one night's king
if that is true then there is a chance
someone might have to replace the night
king we see today maybe that's why the
night king has been taking crashed her
sons he might be looking for someone to
take his place one day but that's just a
guess another piece of evidence that may
support this theory is the fact that the
army of the Dead was not completely
defeated during the first long night
when they came during the long night no
one was able to destroy them entirely in
the world of Ice and Fire book it says
how the long night came to an end is a
matter of legend in the north they
talked about the last hero who sought
out the children of the forest thanks to
the children the first men of the Nights
Watch banded together and they were able
to fight and win the battle for the dawn
the last battle that broke the endless
winter and sent the others fleeing to
the icy north it does not say the White
Walkers in the army of the Dead were
completely destroyed it says they sent
them running to the north so you got to
be asking herself can the knight king
and his army be defeated for good
because if you can defeat them for good
then why didn't they do this the first
time why build a giant wall and create a
Night's Watch unless that's the only way
to try and contain them is it possible
that the children of the forest created
a weapon so dangerous that it can never
be
defeated I suppose anything is possible
however Jon Snow has one thing on his
side that the children of the forest in
the lassie road did not have during the
long night Jon has aligned himself with
Daenerys Targaryen who happens to have
fire-breathing dragons arguably the most
powerful and magical weapon in the realm
other than maybe the knight King but I
guess that's why this is a Song of Ice
and Fire
however it still looks like the knight
King has the upper hand because of the
dragons weren't able to affect him
personally but he was able to kill a
dragon and gain control of it when it
comes to the TV show I think they will
come up with a solution to defeat the
night King for good now I am just basing
this on my own personal opinion but I
don't see them ending it the same way
they did thousands of years ago when the
others fled back to the icy north when
it comes to defeating the night king jon
snow does seem very determined I will
say this though if someone were going to
take the night King's place and it
wasn't Gilley's baby I would like to
think it would be a member from House
Stark because of their connection to the
others after all the first night's King
was a stark according to old nan I don't
think it's too crazy to think another
star could become the leader of the
others basically everything about the
Starks have some sort of connection or
parallel to the White Walkers which I
have won over numerous times in other
videos so I won't repeat all that
information again but this is an
interesting idea if I had to pick what
stark would become the next night King I
would actually go with brain stark
instead of John now I know there is
already a very popular idea that bran
Stark has been the night King the whole
time but that's not what I'm saying here
I'm referring to someone taking his
place in the future as in next season
here is something that might be worth
considering maybe this is why the
children of the forest recruited bran in
the first place if the children of the
forest did create the first night king
and lost control of him maybe they are
thinking this if we can find another
very special person with Starks blood
the blood of the first men that maybe we
can have a chance of getting control
over this dangerous weapon we created
this could be why the children of the
forest and the three-eyed Raven started
to Train bran at a very young age they
might know they created a weapon that
can never be defeated
replaced with a new leader but if they
could train someone from a very young
age to do as they say which they already
do basically have mind control over
brain at this point then it could
actually work they might see this as a
way of containing this deadly outbreak
even though we saw the children die at
the cave that doesn't mean they're all
gone because you never know how many are
still at the gods eye where the main
weirwood system is located what if they
set a trap for brain stark and that's
why he entered the same vision as the
night Cain did they secretly hope the
night King would reach out and grab
Bryan as to mark the next person in line
it was kind of weird that the night king
was just sitting there almost as if he
was waiting for this to happen
not to mention old me and did say the
name of the night's king was Brandon
stark and she also said him and brain
stark slept in the very same room maybe
old names stories actually do predict
the future you see this whole time many
people thought brain stark would go into
the past and inadvertently become the
night King but what if that's not how it
happens what if he volunteers or if he's
tricked into doing this in the future if
he thinks this is the only way to save
the realm then he might consider doing
something like this it could make for
one screwed up ending imagine if a stark
did after sacrifice themselves to an
eternity of what would be equivalent of
a frozen hell beyond the wall not only
would we lose another stark but the show
would also end with Westeros never
really getting to live in peace because
there would always be that threat
looming beyond the wall knowing that one
day things could get out of control all
over again I'm gonna end the video by
saying this I don't believe it will end
this way but I can't sit here and say
it's impossible either just because I
have a different ending in mind what do
all of you think do you agree with the
theory that Jon Snow will become the
next night king or do you think brain
stark makes more sense let me know your
thoughts and questions on all of this
down below in the comment section
anyways I want to thank each and every
one of you for watching the video and
supporting my channel I really
appreciate that and I hope you all have
a great day I'll see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]